oh God he went down range in a bomb suit
with a crowbar I mean cool we would
clown this movie so much in training and
just do the most outlandish because
that's exactly what he did hey everyone
Jay Lee here 13-year Navy explosive
ordinance disposal or EOD vet did four
combat deployments three to Afghanistan
and one to East Africa today we'll be
looking at bomb disposal scenes in
movies and TV and judge how real they
[Music]
are that thing is apparently the
Cadillac of trolley can I say 100% that
this wouldn't be entertained no because
it might but what I do know is there are
probably a dozen other ways to attack
this device from inside the bus I mean
something rudimentary is getting a stick
with some film so we can take an x-ray
of the device so we can actually see
what's going onck I need you to look at
the
wire cover he is talking on a radio and
or a phone right next to this thing it's
electronically initiated they don't know
if that energy will cause that device to
fire or not so that whole thing is not
realistic
whatsoever I can't bypass it'll fire
it's a collapsible circuit yeah
collapsing circuits are real it's you
know there's two or more detonators and
when you cut one the other one will fire
it's common for us to train to that it's
very uh unlikely to encounter that in
well at least in Afghanistan in my
experience we didn't encounter a lot of
collapsing circuits as mainly pressure
plates stuff like that very simple
circuits Howard pain Atlanta PD bomb
squad Z I want you to get out of there
and sit tight we're going to go after
the source no they they should 100% do
something to this device and not just
solely rely on the bomber helping them
out there are tools we have to disrupt
um an IED and a component so it'll
disrupt the firing train it'll disrupt
all the circuitry um and separate
components remotely and then we'll go
down check the disruption and then
separate components further and do our
thing Jack I I believe he is a bomb
disposal officer with the LAPD he should
know these component recognition uh
things and how and and able to identify
how this device works or at least have a
good idea of it this definitely gets to
zero because he knows better and he
should have taken an action he should
have brought a tool down there with him
he could have taped it right next to it
and disrupted that thing right off the
bus we got under 3 minutes left what do
I do first pressure sensors I activate
it when I sat down if I get up my car
explodes this is uh already hokey
because he sat down and now it's now
it's armed and there's a timer in movies
and TV they often incorporate these big
timers where it's counting down to the
detonation but in all reality it's
mainly a safe and arm type mechanism if
I'm a bomb imp Placer I need to be able
to imp place it and then safely get away
so there's a time but you're not going
to see you're not going to see this
giant clock it's like you have five
minutes before you die orange yellow
green colors don't matter what I need
you to do is tell me which one is hot to
the
touch
the warm wire versus cold wires you can
make a circuit with the proper
resistance so none of the wires are warm
so like the movie tropes of the warm
wire and or the colors of the wires is a
total farce I can go to Home Depot
Lowe's whichever hardware store your
your your your hardware store of choice
get any color wire I want right and put
it in here take the small box out of the
kit and turn it
on that kit probably looked like
something I would pull tools from in a
soft Special Operations forces
environment from my experience in
Afghanistan I it was all Special
Operations forces or Naval special
Warfare we flew in helicopters somewhere
landed and ran to a Target right or
walked of a great distance to get to a
Target you really want to limit what you
have on your body so yeah we're not
going to be carrying around briefcases
and backpack just full of
tools
just cut it in the middle the orange
wire between the two
clamps I don't want to get into that
specifically in detail because that uh
is how we attack some certain things but
yeah those clamps are very they're for a
very specific purpose for multiple
detonators and you would need another
item that he doesn't have there to to do
diagnostics uh diagnostic work on that
type of device you would need a little
bit more time I mean a lot more training
than just him saying oh yeah clamping on
the warm wire and then cutting between
it right there's a lot of testing you
have to do before you can cut a wire but
yeah the whole setting him sitting down
in it arming it and then like having
this opportunity to render it safe yeah
you wish so yeah we'll give him a two
we'll give him a
two how it was set up and how it was in
place totally legit he had a claymore he
put on top of the Grand Slam bomb huge
British bomb Claymores that are used all
over they're already wired they're pre
they're pre-made to to be set up as
booby traps that's what they're for um
so he just had the trip wire put um
something that he thought one of these
people chasing him idiots would
grab there are 100% bomb detection dogs
and in this clip those dogs I believe
are going for uh human detection they're
going for sniffing out Rambo not
necessarily sniff out explosive hazards
in the woods and even if they were those
dogs are running full speed that's like
essentially you trying to sniff a hot
dog in the corner while sprinting down
the hallway like hyperventilating
essentially it's never going to
happen would the blast wave be that
extended I mean it was drawn out um to
have that effect the explosive component
in there is torpex they added aluminum
into the the composition of that
explosive to extend the blast but with
that being said that's like a nuclear
blast wave that is just like kind of
continuing to go out it would be really
big and and
done that blast wave would have killed a
lesser man not John Rambo the explosive
component in there is torpex it's about
50% stronger than TNT and that's only
the blast frag goes exponentially
further than blast does so yeah he is
definitely within that this is probably
the most realistic clip as far as how
things function and how people think man
I'm G have to I might give Rambo an
eight he's knocked two because of
survival that's hokey at best even for
John Rambo I got it uh it's a cylinder
Cipher du U
NN it's my last name it knows who I am
if someone is just going to make an
improvised nuclear device like this
Cipher anything is possible there's many
ways that uh nuclear weapons are armed
you can't get into any specifics there's
state sponsored and then there's
non-state sponsored State sponsor going
to have all kinds of different protocols
in place safeties what have you arming
sequences non-state sponsored if if
someone is just going to make an
improvised nuclear device like this
Cipher it can be armed when it hears
your voice when my voice whatever the
case may be I speak without a math I fly
through the air a without wings what am
I an
echo that's it that's it that's I can't
I I can't even with this one this is
this is he's talking to it how does he
know if he answers this question it's
not going to go
off it's empty apparently it was a mud
suck right a hoax ID um or a hoax device
real life hoaxes are actually very
common very common especially in Iraq
and Afghanistan um they were utilized as
intelligence gathering devices
essentially they' put it in the road
totally fake just something that would
key up EOD response an EOD response and
then they would be watching and
videotaping the whole procedure despite
all of the craziness that was in the
scene using a hoax to gather
intelligence on people and to learn more
about them absolutely true we'll give
this one a eight up there with Rambo
oh God we would clown this movie so much
in training like we would just pretend
we're this dude and just do the most
outlandish because that's exactly what
he did uh he's attacking a vbid uh which
is a vehicle born improvised explosive
device walking up to a vbid without a
tool an explosive tool an energetic tool
or anything not even a pole line or
anything to prosecute this this vehicle
is just dumb he went down range in a
bomb suit with a crowbar I mean cool
they would probably send a robot down
with a tool first right especially cuz
yeah that's a lot of H A vbit is no joke
there's a I mean even the even the guys
on the wall his security element they'd
probably die if that thing went
off the hell is he
doing
dead dead he could have died a half
dozen to a dozen ways in this in this
clip alone not to mention the whole
movie kicking it randomly opening the
opening the trunk by hand opening the
hood by hand turning the windshield
wipers on yanking random wires
underneath the hood like any one of
those could have set that thing off yeah
I think he removed his headset please
put your headset back
on the most realistic thing in there was
the was the radio thing he actually took
his headset off so he could focus and
and and get his thought process going
and then when they asked him to put it
back on yeah that's probably response
that you would get from from uh an EOD
Tech we definitely render safe IEDs by
hand I've done it um and it's not ideal
we want to go as remote as possible
because of the risk of something going
off but yeah he could have done a lot
more with his hands like cut de cord um
detonating cord right out right at the
gate I forgot how many were how many
155s but that that's what was in the
trunk of that car once he saw the the
main charge and that's what he should be
going after anyway just Reckless abandon
yeah this is just it's totally Hollywood
it up the only realistic thing was the
communication aspect of it he gets a one
one out of
[Music]
10 3 miles underwater the water's
crystal clear so I mean
that's no there's no way my fourth team
I was on a mine countermeasure team but
it was underwater sea mines and
underwater IEDs and stuff like that this
is supposed to be a nuke that has fallen
into the abyss it's a big deal when we
go to 200 ft of seawater we're
definitely not going to do free Ascent
to the bottom there's always descent
lines we we establish a safe area yeah
he doesn't have any search tools
whatsoever he just has his eyeballs and
a flare which is insane and that's just
the div aspect so we haven't even gotten
to the EOD part of
it we made it we'll go step by step the
communication is totally Wu it's three
miles underwater what RF signal can
reach can penetrate three miles worth of
of water we do have very rudimentary
ways of communicating I.E a float on the
top of the water that's connected to us
via a line and we'll just pull it and
the certain number of pulls means a
certain thing so we communicate like
that in a bottom line Centric
environment where we're taking seismic
and magnetic precautions but yeah nuke
that is a totally different ball game
you have to cut the ground wire not the
lead
wire without getting into any super
specifics on nuclear weapons design we
would have researched this ordinance
item this is exactly how you render it
safe if we want to separate components
separate the fuse from it sometimes we
do that explosively sometimes we do it
mechanically and then we just raise it
up and bring it to the beach and exploit
it on the surface I'd have to give that
a big fat Donut for realism a zero
because that's not at all how nuclear
weapons
function here backy can you hear me I
love this show it's so funny unexploded
ordinance uxo um those are very common
because sometimes fuse is just dut out
and it's still a threat because we just
don't know the condition of it right why
did it not go off is it a time is it a
proximity thing is it a is it a delay
that just hasn't gone all the way yet so
very much a concern let's hope for
everyone else that's behind cover but
mainly for the guys that are right on
top of it heartbeat
regular you spring a leak stop diing it
is definitely plausible to use a
stethoscope to examine a suspected
Clockwork fuse seems hokey but yeah that
is old school legit it was a thing for
old bombs like that they had Clockwork
mechanisms in the fuse that you could
hear ticking down we don't see that a
lot anymore that was a lot of training
in school um just to get the exposure to
it was a propaganda bomb leaflets are
definitely employed they were dropped in
all over um Europe during World War II
they were employed in I mean North Korea
Vietnam leaflets are definitely a type
of psychological warfare or even just a
means to communicate with uh a
population that just
is confined to an area but I give it a
solid seven for realism granted two
random people would not be working on
this on this bomb but yeah so we got to
dock it a little bit I just don't know
why they didn't have any bomb squad
people so on the side out of the timer
there should be a serial number that'll
tell me which wire y'all need to cut
Archer here is showing an inexperienced
person being coach through this whole
ordeal like many other movies and TV
shows it would be almost impossible um
unless it was set up exactly how the
manufacturer wanted to be set up if
that's the case totally doable right I
can walk you through anything it's like
okay cool how many Wares are there what
colors are they you
ready first letter is B Bravo thanks
second letter is m m is in Mike oh my
God that is so spoton as far as
Communications especially when hitting
the fan H I can relate you have radio
frequencies you have interference you
have distance you have other things in
the way so your signal can be degraded
everyone is getting ramped up in this
episode but in real life when stuff is
going on and comms are an an issue you
just really stay calm and cool and
Collective on the radio that way even if
it is weak a weak signal you can still
hear what's being said I'm doing it God
oh my God R what's going on the timer
sped up the Trope here with the green wi
being cut and speeding up the clock is
just erroneous it makes no sense to have
that feature in there unless you're
trying to create some type of anxiety
and in real life trust me if you're
faced with a live explosive that can
detonate at any action keeping that at
Bay is already going to be uh difficult
enough so yeah at the end of the day
people want their things to go off so
that's how they make them I'll give them
a four the communication piece that was
hilariously accurate bombs aren't on the
same fire line I have to diffuse them
individually how long is it going to
take I got to find them and then
dismantle them 30 minutes there's just
like a chunk of high explosive taped to
a pipe EOD would see that and boom and
make a call and everyone would get out
of there except for one other person him
and one other security person and then
I'm going to take immediate action on
that device um and immediate is
immediate it's not 30
minutes he was using a mirror for
whatever reason I'm not going to use a a
a an inspection mirror when I have my
eyeballs and I can see all the way
around it so yeah that's kind of hokey
he's got nods on his helmet so that's um
combersome especially when he's working
on that one that was at head level his
nods could hit it and if there's an
anti- move thing on there boom he just
functioned it as designed so I would
take my helmet off so there's nothing um
no obstructions that could potentially
hit this
device if he's the only one there yeah
that's what he's got to do it's because
it's threat assessment of what's going
to kill me right now that's an enemy
combatant he's probably going to kill me
if he sees me so that needs to be taken
care of first but yeah he would have at
least one one shooter with him a little
bit ways so when I'm working um I can be
focused on this they could have classed
it up a little bit but all
good Bingo he did use ceramic scissors
at the end I thought that was a nice
touch granted he used ceramic scissors
instead of diagonal cutters and
typically when wires are coiled up like
that there's two of them and he cut them
both he could have smooshed the two
wires that are conductive together and
set it off yeah there's a lot of hokey
stuff so yeah it's got to be low low
three towards the general direction of
the mountain the robot rely finds what
you're looking for they're in Helman
which I was also in Helman uh Helman
provin in Afghanistan and yeah robots
are awesome I didn't see the robot go
down with the tool tool in tool out
that's what we do that's what's preached
from day one in EOD School the robot has
Cutters on it it has grippers and
separate components whatever the case
may be so if it did find something it
could countercharge it or they could set
it down
[Music]
no at the end of the day that is what a
robot is for they are expendable devices
if worst comes the worst they find
something by functioning it it blows up
Not a Human Being the entire team was
was standing out in front of the
vehicles that's totally not what would
happen they would be inside their
vehicle driving this robot that way you
have um mitigation from fragmentation
coming at you at least be behind the
vehicle for God's sake I need you to
keep your
head
still
don't this is a close pin switch very
old very
rudimentary very easy to defeat Nick the
EOD operator should have seen that he
identified that it's a pull cool cut it
right just cut it and be done with it
but he did the thing of holding his head
you tell someone that they're connected
to a line with a bunch of explosives
they're going to freak out that's one of
the one of the rare times where you you
can actually attack a switch it's a very
clear
cut we
need that could have been handled way
differently and then everyone would have
survived it's tough you know a lot of a
lot of EOD procedures and tactics are
Written in Blood just like this the
survivors like okay this is exactly what
they encountered over the radio this is
what was said now we have our new set of
TTP
so it doesn't happen again I'll be this
one to five it's got some stuff some
super hokey stuff but uh all in all not
bad what are you doing I can get it out
over the
B the plausibility of having a bomb that
is unable to be rendered safe it's all a
matter of time really if time is you
know not not an object then yeah you can
you can spend the time and the diligence
and really get it disassembled to where
it's you know it's demilled so now you
have to weigh can I render this safe in
a minute and 30 seconds or not and the
answer is probably no right because
especially with a device as
sophisticated as that was supposed to be
your best case is you have a minute 30
to get this as far away from everyone as
possible
yeah water is a great uh has a great
tamping effect because it cannot
compress it really depends on what the
actual explosive the nuclear yield of
this bomb was and how deep it was able
to go the mission of EOD is protection
of personal and property so yeah getting
that device out in a way moving it
relocating it even if it's to your own
demise is what we would do um for the
sake of protecting personnel and
property is it a nine can Batman be a
nine I'll give it a nine I like to think
his actions were genuine of Navy EOD I'm
gonna have to say my favorite bomb
disposal scene of all time has got to be
the scene in mcrubber totally outlandish
but so funny but if I'm going for
something with good sediment then today
we saw that Batman video and I think
that really captured the quintessential
mindset of Navy EOD about eliminating a
threat to civilian population and
mitigating the risk and moving it away
hey everyone thanks for watching if you
thought this video is the bomb pun
intended go ahead watch the next
[Music]
video